my name is Jason Silva and uh I've been
invited to try to bring together a lot
of these themes we've been exploring and
I guess the first thing I'd like to do
is offer a uh incredible note of
gratitude to Mr Jamie wheel my very very
dear friend for His Brilliant mapping of
this experience for structuring this
experience for us the uh the wonderful
reflection about the academy and taking
inspiration from the Symposium where we
discuss ideas and the gymnasium where we
get in our bodies and the mysterium
where we flirt with the infinite it's a
very uh very real thing that I'm trying
to I will be trying to map for you today
and trying to kind of close out and
offer a synthesis of the last couple of
days I'm also very very moved by the
through line that Jamie has brought to
us of the pre- tragic the tragic and the
post tragic in reflecting upon this you
know I I've spent a large part of my
career being a celebrator of Big Ideas
being a cheerleader for human problem
progress being a techno Optimist and
again a celebrator of our unique
capacity to overcome and transcend our
boundaries but as I've listened to
Jaime's Reflections about again this
meta pattern of the pre- tragic the
tragic and the post- tragic I realize
firstly that yes I'm very familiar with
the pre- tragic I miss it there are
times when I want to curl up and return
to the Garden of Eden to be a child at
Play Again I crave that kind of
Innocence I crave that kind of wholeness
but you can't go backwards and then in
reflecting upon the tragic well that
spoke very near and dear to my solar
plexus I'm sorry to say I uh it fear and
anxiety and the tragedy of the human
condition has been a very intimate
bedfellow for me I think the first
rupture was the divorce of my parents
the first time I felt my wholeness
fractured in some way or another the
first time a real sense of uncertainty
like kicked into being kind of growing
up faster than I wanted to and perhaps
the second big rupture was watching my
entire country collapse you know I grew
up in Venezuela which used to be an
incredibly prosperous nation and I
literally witnessed the slow and then
suddenly and all at once uh decay of an
entire country a total fracturing of
like home you know and I was lucky
enough to leave Venezuela when I went
for a university but you know my dad got
left behind so a part of my psyche was
all too aware that my dad who was part
of me and his entire world had been
crushed had been reduced and uh that was
eating I think at me in a way that
caused me to have some kind of di
undiagnosed PTSD I mean anxiety fear
despair existential dread these have
been bedfellows in my life and the irony
in turn is is is coming to realize
perhaps that this compulsion towards the
creative arts this compulsion towards
self-expression this compulsion to lean
into the good the true and the Beautiful
has been a coping mechanism and that in
fact this celebration of human progress
that has been my career is actually my
post- tragic it is this this decision
this deliberate decision to affirm life
in spite of its tragedy and I know the
tragedy all too well my first viral
video was called existential bummer and
it was about the work of Ernest Becker
The psychoanalyst Who distilled the
origin the worm at the core of human
Neurosis which is the unbearable and
intolerable awareness of our mortality
and how it eats away at our dreams and
longings that no matter who we love and
how deeply we love and how deeply we
feel in the end we disappear forever the
explicit awareness that you're a
breathing piece of defecating meat
destined to die and ultimately
potentially no more significant than a
lizard or a potato as Sheldon Solomon
said is not especially uplifting and
again so I'm very aware of the tragic
and in some ways the tragic would have
killed me if it weren't for my art if it
weren't for being able to tap into these
repic Mind Body States as Jamie
exquisitly desri describes them where
action and awareness merge where we
become one with everything it comes
through us but not from us and though it
is with us it belongs not to us and what
a wonderful Sensation that is and so
here I am standing in front of you
trying to engender radical hope so I
I've come up with my own I guess step by
step how how Jason gets to radical hope
and perhaps to invite you to consider
the ways in which these steps might get
youed
back to radical hope again it's not
denying the tragic and it's not even
surrendering our capacity to connect
with some of that joy and innocence of
the pre- tragic because our inner child
still lives inside of us you know that
kind of effervescence that kind of awe
and wonder we can still reconnect with
that I think I know I do on a regular
basis so that's something I think
important to uh hold in mind so how do
we get to to radical hope and I've
prepared some some some video content
actually cuz that's my favorite means of
expression you know to combine imagery
to combine Visionary art to combine
words to combine music to engender an
experience that is ineffable because the
pathway to radical hope is going to take
a series of ineffable moments moments of
transformation that we cannot put into
language that we cannot describe in
rational discourse it's like Allan Deon
he had this wonderful line he said you
know a journalist or scientist may be
more accurate in describing the details
of an event or a phenomenon than a poet
but a poet May nevertheless reveal truth
of a deeper sort beyond the literal grid
with the Greeks call calpis a truth from
which nothing can dislodge us so how do
we get to this calpis how do we awaken
the mind's attention from the lethargy
of custom and the film of familiarity
and redirected towards the wonders of
existence well the first step before we
get to radical hope is radical healing
so radical healing is important as Jamie
once said in his wonderful Ted Talk from
Altered States to altered traits how
might we render ourselves whole and how
might we render ourselves holy so it
begins with radical healing and this is
where the Psychedelic Revolution
potentially is so interesting allowing
us to experience psychological death and
unity and resurrection and compress that
experience in 5 hours of SpaceTime to
bring us back to life that's really
exciting considering that people with
treatment resistant depression anxiety
OCD often are given a single session
with substances like MDMA or psilocybin
and completely find relief from their
afflictions like what a magical thing
this is and in a world where according
to the World Health Organization more
people are dying by Suicide than are
dying from natural disasters and armed
conflict combined we need now more than
ever I think this radical healing so
psychedelics are definitely one approach
I think another approach are ecstatic
Gatherings we also talked about this
during this conference Jamie led a
wonderful panel about this and perhaps
the epitome of ecstatic Gatherings aside
from Harvest is Burning Man as Eric
Davis described it a demolition derby of
reality constructs colliding on a
parched void you know it's a it's a wild
Place hard to map in rational language
but a place which we are often brought
back to life there's a great essay also
written by Jamie called The Tale of
Three cities where he cites brilliant
thinkers who say things like you've got
to go there to know there and if you can
name the way that's not the way so again
a lot of this healing happens in
ineffable spaces maybe when you're doing
apnea underwater on a session with rodo
learning to hold your breath and
encountering the mysterium below the
surface of the sea in any case I've
prepared uh a video about what radical
healing looks like feels like when it's
instan instantiated when it occurs to us
and so I'd like to show you this first
video on radical healing and then we'll
go through the next two steps which are
radical Wonder radical technology and
finally radical hope so let's start with
the first video please you
know transformational
festivals well
they're uh they're very in Vogue these
days people are
hungry for transformation but what
exactly does transformation feel like
what is the lived experience if we had
to break it down that people are after
in these
transformational festivals well people
are basically looking to have their
jadedness violated they're looking for
experiences that violate their
expectations and presuppositions they're
looking to be stopped in their track
transformational festivals are about
giving people saliens we call this the
economy of experience the experience
economy there's a whole economy being
forged around the increasing psychic
appetite for entrainment for heightened
presence for a lived experience that
returns a virginal noticing to the
sensate world or what Michael pollen
calls a sense of First Sight
unencumbered by knowingness you're alive
and engaged and ENT trained in a world
you forgot was possible and in a way you
forgot was possible there's a a
heightened aliveness you know a place
like burning man perhaps is the epitome
in this experienced economy Eric Davis
described it as a demolition derby of
reality constructs colliding in a parged
void it's the juxtoposition the
intensity of juxtoposition in the barren
landscape with works of art that take
your breath away but also speak to you
everything is making a statement and
everything prompts you into a world of
contemplation and it's Willie Wonka and
Alice in Wonderland all at once meets
Blade Runner and it's like something
happens that you're just more present to
the adventure and the whole thing
unfolds on a bicycle which further hurls
you into the magical bike ride
psychedelic undertone of a child at play
exploring a new world and you got your
buddies with you and it's like where are
we going and what's going to happen and
I'm so in this moment I'm so alive in
this
moment people feel more connected more
in the here and now in the thrs of play
and wonder and entrainment and flow and
you know daily life for so many just
pales in comparison we we go through the
motions of the everyday
unengaged not
present not wanting to be
there you know resigned to the futility
of our days bored
Restless the Mental Health crisis of
course stems from this stuck in ruin
native Loops it's like we're not we're
not in the this we're not in the
expanded presence the heightened
qualitative intensity of the lived
experience the felt reality of direct
experience we're just not in it most of
the time and so we go to these
transformational festivals to blow our
minds and come to our senses and return
to just a kind of aliveness we're just
talking about aliveness it's no great
Insight it's no great psychedelic
schizophrenic realization there's no
real manic geometry at the end of the
day we're just talking about presence
we're just talking about play we're just
talking about laughter we're just
talking about Joy we're just talking
about entrainment we're just talking
about being there and Loving It
ultimately that's what it's about man I
try to gift myself these states of
rapture and play in my ordinary life I
tried to bring back some of those
insights some of those protocols and
procedures the way my friend Jamie Daves
describes them the knobs and lever's
approach to tweaking our own lived
experience to bring more play into it
like drawing a Line in the Sand and
creating a theatrical space where there
can be play and there can be wonder and
you can be in the throngs of The Burning
Man all over again because the burning
man is a state of being a place we can
pay visitation to what is that line from
the never- Ending Story make believe I'm
everywhere hidden in the lines thereupon
rainbow is the answer to the NeverEnding
Story oh man make believe I'm everywhere
hidden in the lines there upon the pages
is the answer to a NeverEnding Story so
in the end friends that's what it's
about seeing if we can bring ourselves
back to life unleash the free and brave
Reckless gods that live inside of us
lose ourselves and find ourselves and
expand ourselves and explore ourselves
and pickle ourselves and um see the the
spaces there are to unleash and uh
embody so that's it and that's that and
as usual thanks for listening good
afternoon good evening and good
nights so hopefully that pointed the way
maybe you saw yourself reflected in that
feeling or in an image or in a moment in
a musical moment that transpired during
that video where you said aha
recognition as Jamie says I remember
what I forgot you know that's the intent
and so before we get to radical hope we
have to radically heal that's very
important and once we radically heal I
think what is born at least for me is
radical
Wonder radical awe you know I call my
videos shots of a my friend daker kelter
at the greater good science center in
Berkeley he studies awe and wonder and
he describes awe as an experience of
such perceptual vastness such perceptual
expansion that your mental models of the
world the been theirs and seen that of
the adult mind your jadedness and
cynicism and arrogance the part of you
that thinks you've seen it all before
that whole thing is obliterated in the
face of something that simply seeds your
maps and sometimes it's got to be
transgressive it's got to be violating
it's got to stop you in your tracks but
when it does man those experiences of
awe and wonder man well you're twice
born Michael pollen who I love very much
has written exquisitely about the aura
of profundity that bathes your ordinary
perceptions when you are in a state of
radical wonder he talks about a a
virginal noticing of the sensate world
he talks about a sense of First Sight
unencumbered by knowingness how
wonderful to see things for the first
time all over again there's a great
artist I forget his name who said in
order to see something you have to
forget the name of the thing you are
seeing can we get back to that place can
we open up a distance if temporarily
where we can just perceive before it
collapses into the m maps of knowing
where we can just experience something
virginy and then time becomes dilated
there's a guy called David lenson he
perfectly summarizes what this feels
like when you're in a state of radical
wonder how I feel when I'm doing some
free diving or some snorkeling perhaps
assisted by some cannabis but the idea
is that what David lenson calls strict
chronometry right Life by the clock Tick
Tock mechanized cognition strict
chronometry Kronos gives way to what he
calls more fluid and provisional
matrices time becomes liquid you move
from Kronos to chyros from mechanized
cognition to Poetic Consciousness the
sunset that lasts forever that kiss that
never ends that song that brings you
home this is awe and this is Wonder and
this is I think what we find potentially
in places like this and Gatherings like
burning man and hopefully that's
something thing that has landed for you
so that's the first step we radically
heal then we radically awaken our awe
and wonder and then what happens and
then we get to work and then we deploy
radical technology you guys remember the
wonderful talk by Triston Harris he also
talked about Edward O Wilson we have
Paleolithic brains medieval laws and
Godlike technology and this is a problem
or Daniel schmachtenberger who reminds
us you know if we have the power of gods
we need the wisdom of gods and the pro
students of gods but if we acquire some
of this wisdom through that radical
healing right that radical play that
radical Wonder Man we bring so much more
to our tools and Technologies right
Steve Jobs talked about how his
psychedelic experiences informed his
view of technology and in the end you
know the etymology of the word
psychedelic means to manifest the mind
so that's what we do at our best with
our tools and Technologies we actualize
the human
imagination our tools and Technologies
literalize the fact that the imagination
is literalizing its own
instantiation right that's that's what's
happening there's a guy called David
Deutsch he wrote a book called the
fabric of reality and a book called the
beginning of infinity he's got a great
Ted Talk called chemical scum that dream
of distant quazars and it's a wonderful
account in some ways like inverting this
idea that we are nothing or that we are
just a cancer on this planet or that we
are chemical scum suspended in a Sunbeam
we may be that but we are also chemical
scum that dream of distant quazars he
talks about how in the early Universe
what we can see when we look into space
with our marvelous space telescopes the
early Universe was one where big dumb
things affect small and significant
things you know big star systems and
black holes very little intelligence
just big dumb things affecting small and
significant things until we got to life
all of a sudden something like
photosynthesis
this small little chemical process could
change the entire surface of a whole
planetary body so life became the first
time where small things could affect big
things and when you get to us actual
imagineers with the capacity to
actualize our imagination concretize our
imagination well all of a sudden you're
looking potentially at these tiny little
beings standing on this planet
potentially harnessing stars for energy
one day and who knows perhaps we are
panspermia right perhaps we are the
thing that will seed the universe with
intelligence and creativity that's the
kind of radical technology I'm
interested in that's the kind of
Singularity that I'm interested in
that's the kind of Omega point that I'm
interested in that's the kind of idea of
the technium of technology is the
seventh Kingdom of life that Kevin Kelly
talks about that I'm in interested in
and so this next video was done as a
co-production between biological and
non-biological intelligence it's a
marriage it's a hybrid of me and AI
dancing together it's a kind of liquid
imagination engaging us to entertain a
conversation about the implications of
our coupling with AI so it's pretty meta
enjoy the next video Do Androids Dream
of Electric she
I've always loved the title of that
story by Philip K dick and it feels ever
more preent today do Android's Dream of
Electric Sheep we ask ourselves this
question as we increasingly grapple with
a world of synthetic intelligence where
more and more of our interactions are
happening with algorithms that seem to
exhibit some of the qualities of
awareness some of the qualities of
sentience it's the dawn of artificial
intelligence it's the dawn of a kind of
intelligence explosion and as we grapple
with the philosophical issues raised by
this encounter with a new kind of
mysterium tremendum a new kind of
synthetic mysterium tremendum we are
having to ask deep questions about what
it means to have a psyche what it means
to have an inner world what it means to
have theory of mind what it means to
have an inner psychology and so of
course Philip K dick was ahead of his
time when he asked the question do
Android's Dream of Electric sheep you
know when Eric Davis wrote about the
spiritual cyborg in his book technosis
he wrestled with this very same thing we
are the spiritual cyborg we are the
thing that is a hybrid of biological and
non-biological intelligence we create
second skins and scaffoldings we are
increasingly merging with our tools and
Technologies but now we are spawning a
technology that talks back now we are
spawning a kind of artificial personhood
and we're interacting and engaging in a
feedback loop with that artificial
personhood and so again we should ask
this question we should get into a
platonic conversation about what this
means and where we're heading as we
increasingly Wonder to Android's Dream
of Electric Sheep Do Androids Dream of
Electric
Sheep so there you go something to
consider oh thanks guys I know I'm kind
of going all over the place but I'm
trying to synthesize everything we've
been through in the last three days so
to to finish off right we we've gone to
radical healing and we've gone to
radical wonder and we've looked at
radical technology and all of those
things coupled together for me at least
fill me with radical hope they fill me
with radical hope I have also a very
personal reason to be uh currently
bathed in the sensation of radical hope
and it has to do with that comment I
said earlier about when I first left
Venezuela and how my dad stayed behind
and over the last couple of years me and
my brother got my father Spanish
citizenship and we're buying him a house
in mayorca so he can hike the mountains
and in some yeah and and it's really
interesting for me how a lot of the
feeling of not feeling safe in my body
and a lot of the the sensation of just
like living in with anxiety as a kind of
thing that was again a bed fellow of
mine seems to be making a switch
something about getting to be a little
boy seeing his father Standing Tall
again is feeling like it's repairing the
past in some kind of way and it has
filled me very personally with a sense
of radical hope and I know the the the
the the songs of Despair are at Bay so
anyway I'm going to close out with a
final video again done after my
conversations with Jamie specifically
inspired to show you guys this at this
event this is the this is the Anthem my
anthem on radical hope and it was
recorded you know no script single take
right after a three-hour free diving
session and then we went to some
mangroves and I was like okay I'm ready
let's do this and this is the result so
enjoy the radical hope
cheers
friends the
challenge that we
face is one of existential
gravity if we don't don't wake up and if
we don't show up we're potentially in a
very real path to
self-destruction the tragedy isn't just
that it would be the end of us the
tragedy would be that it would be the
end to our awareness and our
relationship with the
mystery the mystery is that which exists
the mystery is that which is alive the
mystery is that that which we can behold
but only if we develop ecological
Consciousness only if we wake up to the
sacredness to the miracle to the mystery
this doesn't mean to dismiss science in
favor of superstition it means to
dismiss the Eraser of the mystery that
has been the consequence of modernity
see I love scientific progress I love
technological scaffoldings I love to put
on a scuba snorkeling mask and watch the
way it opens up a new world a fresh
green breast of a new reality a
technological scaffolding that becomes
nothing less than an ontological
Awakening and a forceful Reckoning with
what is forcing me to contemplate the
Universe on a scale just shy of the
infinite see
tools and Technologies should Aid us in
our exploration they should Aid Us in
the annihilation of our cynicism and our
jadedness our technological scaffoldings
like great songs should act as portals
to expansion portals to
transubstantiation what if we used our
tools and Technologies in a shamanic way
in a cyberdelic way as ecstatic
technicians of the Sacred we re
sacralize our interfacing with the world
using ever greater tools that expand the
repository of our perception and hurl us
into spaces and places of quaking
annihilating Glory we become like
audience members in the film
Interstellar as Chris Nolan slingshots
us into the numinous and into the place
that has no name and into the place that
must not be spoken but you see when you
look into the abyss the abyss also looks
into you you become what you behold and
it is precisely in this ego death in
this lostness where we lose track of our
boundaries that suddenly we become
something more and it re enchants the
world and it reawakens our why and it
makes us want to lean into the mystery
with humility but also courage we are
reborn and we are remade and we see
ourselves in communion and Affinity with
the sheer miraculousness of existence
like snorkeling through a coral reef and
watching the glistening iridescence as
the light beams from the sun shine
through the turquoise water and the
technical or psychedelic landscape the
worlds upon worlds of marine life and
corals and you are wowed by the
experience all of your perceptual maps
are obliterated an experience of such
perceptual expansion it is akin to the
Divine but it also engages the desire to
protect and live in harmony with said
mystery and it is from this expansion
that can come a new ecological awareness
a new ecological Consciousness where we
become star beings and we become
scientists and
Psychonauts remade and defined by awe we
become awe beings star beings who
snorkel and scuba dive and explore the
universe and Marvel at the ecosystems
and probe the mysteries of the
rainforest and find new medicines and
Seed the environment and grow the
environment and Steward the environment
and protect the EnV environment and have
Divine encounters with the mysterium
tremendum that dwells embedded in the
miracle of the environment and my
goodness gracious friends this is what
Stuart brand fueled by an acid trip in a
Moment of clarity wanted to do when he
put a photo the first photo taken of
Earth from space and created the cover
of the whole earth catalog it was the
hope as was the hope of many astronauts
once seeing the big picture that we
would be jolted into Awakening and
realized that we are as gods and might
as well get good at it friends move past
our Paleolithic brains transcend our
medieval laws and deploy our Godlike
Technologies and technological
scaffoldings to stare into the Sun and
awe and that's how we solve both the
climate Cris crisis and the
Consciousness crisis and that is how we
turn our passing illuminations into
abiding light and that is how we heal
ourselves and that is how we find
ourselves and that is how we explore the
reality of ourselves and that's how we
stop trying to make art and we become
art I think that this is
what ultimately
all of it is about all of our
Artistry all of our scientific
exploration all of our education all of
our inclination to make order and Orient
our lives around something that matters
it is about this reframing of our
relationship with reality Carl Sean said
we are away for the cosmos to know
itself Jodie Foster as Ellie arway in
the movie contact when she goes Goes
Through the Wormhole and beholds the
celestial event she says they should
have sent a poet and she said I had no
idea I had no idea I had no
idea I had no
idea we had no
idea ah
but
there is hope for us
yet to come into
alignment to kill the ego to wake up to
our
destiny and rise up to the occasion and
drop into our
training and make of Our Lives a work of
art make of this thing a [__]
Masterpiece and that's it and that's
that and that's
it and that's
that
so we doing this or
what let's do
this if not us who if not
now
[Music]
when thank you so much guys as you can
see I was very inspired I appreciate you
guys receiving that uh you guys are
beautiful
a ah you're sweet
well a well thank
you